[Musica]
in sardegna il termine poesia viene
utilizzato con un'accezione leggermente
diversa rispetto a quella che abbiamo
imparato a scuola ci hanno insegnato che
la poesia è un testo scritto un composto
diversi di rime di strofe e che l'esito
creativo del processo di meditazione di
un poeta nell'immaginario collettivo il
poeta giacomo leopardi che sta nel suo
studio chino sulla sua scrivania
comporre i suoi versi a crearli e ad
affrontarli su carta bene in sardegna la
poesia è anche questo nell'isola è
attestato una produzione poetica in
lingua sarda almeno dal sedicesimo
secolo almeno dal 1500 e ancora oggi
sono numerosissimi i sardi che dal nord
a sud dell'isola compongono versi in
lingua sarda ma in sardegna il termine
poesia viene utilizzato anche per
riferirsi a un altro fenomeno con
un'altra accezione ben diverso da quello
che ho appena descritto che il fenomeno
della poesia improvvisata
i sardi la definiscono poesia a bonus
poesia al volo o cantù dese e canto per
se stessi per distinguerlo appunto dalla
poesia detta a tavolino cioè la poesia
di meditazione
in entrambi i casi si tratta di creare
versi e di maneggiare rime ma questi due
fenomeni sono in realtà ben diversi tra
loro
la prima è una poesia scritta cioè la
scrittura è il mezzo attraverso cui i
versi vengano formalizzati e fatti
circolare
la seconda invece una poesia orale i
versi non vengono scritti vengono
improvvisati sul momento e vengono
presentati al pubblico tramite il canto
sì proprio il canto perché la poesia
improvvisata non è mai recitato
declamata ma è sempre cantata e il canto
del poeta viene accompagnato o da un
coro di voci o da qualche strumento
musicale
un'altra differenza consiste nel fatto
che la poesia di meditazione e
tipicamente un'attività individuale
di solito il poeta crede
e a compone i suoi versi stando da solo
mentre la poesia improvvisata e sempre
un'attività collettiva che si pratica in
occasioni pubbliche rituali che sono le
cosiddette gare poetiche la si chiama
anche poesia a contrasto perché in una
gara poetica devono sempre essere
presenti almeno due poeti che dialogano
tra loro che competono che si
confrontano
poi ci sono i musicisti che li
accompagnano
e poi c'è il pubblico al quale i poeti
si rivolgono e dal quale cercano il
consenso che un elemento fondamentale
nelle gare poetiche senza il pubblico la
poesia improvvisata non avrebbe senso
senza il pubblico la poesia improvvisata
non potrebbe esistere
infine è profondamente diverso è il
rapporto con il tempo e con lo spazio
scrivere una poesia non pone limiti
temporali il poeta potrebbe lavorare una
sola quartina per giorni per mesi per
anni potrebbe buttarla giù di getto
mettono da una parte poi riprenderla
dopo mesi e magari sistemarla cambia
sostituire qualche termine con un
aggettivo potrebbe limarla nella forma e
solo quando quella quartina quella
poesia sarà pronta potrà essere
pubblicata
e sarà libera di circolare nello spazio
e nel tempo grazie alla scrittura
noi oggi possiamo leggere versi che sono
stati composti da poeti secoli fa magari
in luoghi lontanissimi rispetto a quelli
in cui noi ci troviamo in questo momento
al contrario la poesia improvvisata
esiste in un tempo e in uno spazio
limitato
una gara poetica si tiene in un
determinato luogo e in un determinato
momento e almeno che non la si registri
l'unico modo per assistervi essere lì in
quel luogo e in quel momento è limitato
e anche il tempo che i poeti hanno a
disposizione per creare i loro versi se
durante una gara poetica un poeta si
rivolge a un altro gli facendogli una
domanda e con lui avrà pochi secondi al
limite pochi minuti per pensare la sua
risposta alzarsi andare davanti al
microfono e cantarla di fronte al
pubblico
in sardegna abbiamo quattro diverse
tradizioni di poesia improvvisata
alcune sono più diffuse altre lo sono
meno e si distinguono tra loro per una
serie di caratteristiche
il primo luogo la varietà linguistica
utilizzata alcune tradizioni alcune di
queste quattro tradizioni utilizzano il
sardo logudorese quindi il sardo del
centro nord
altre il sardo campidanese quello del
sud sono diverse le genealogie dei poeti
nel senso che ogni poeta normalmente si
dedica o pratica la poesia solo di una
di queste tradizione mai di una e poi di
un'altra
sono diverse le aree di diffusione sono
diverse le forme metri che utilizzate
alcune delle quali sono estremamente
complesse le più complesse al mondo è
diverso il modo in cui il canto del
poeta viene accompagnato e ancora è
diverso il modo le regole sono diverse
le regole della gara è diverso il modo
in cui la gara si svolge ma queste
quattro tradizioni hanno anche degli
aspetti comuni a partire dal fatto che
la gara è un complesso evento rituale o
meglio forse potremmo dire che esistono
due livelli di pratica c'è un livello di
pratica amatoriale coltivato da
tantissimi appassionati in sardegna che
si riuniscono si incontrano nelle case
private in occasioni informali o in
riunioni organizzate apposta per
praticare la poesia e cantano improvvisa
non lo fanno tra loro per il piacere di
farlo per l'amicizia per la passione di
stare assieme
e poi c'è un altro livello che quello
delle gare professionistiche che in
sardegna viene coltivato da pochi
bravissimi poeti improvvisatori sono più
o meno poche decine in tutta in tutta
l'isola oggi e solo loro hanno la
capacità e l'esperienza di condurre di
portare avanti una gara poetica
professionistica queste gare nuovamente
si tengono in occasione delle feste in
onore dei santi
il comitato organizzatore della festa è
anche colui che seleziona e invita i
poeti che prenderanno parte alla festa
in una delle piazze più importanti del
paese della città con cui si tiene la
gara viene allestito un palcoscenico sul
quale poeta appunto non è mai da soli
e poi ci sono sempre almeno due
si posizionano sul palco in una maniera
che è definita dalla tradizione nei loro
postura i loro gesti loro comportamenti
sono tutti definiti dalla tradizione da
questo appunto complesso rituale il
sistema più diffuso di improvvisazione
in sardegna e quello detto a contrasto
cioè il comitato che organizza la festa
che organizza la gara sceglie dei temi
contrapposti possono essere la luce e il
buio o la giustizia divina la giustizia
terrena se i politi sono due oppure il
mare la terra il cielo se per esempio
poeti sono tre i poeti estraggono a
sorte uno di questi temi poco prima che
la gara abbia inizio
è il loro compito il compito del poeta è
quello di salire sul palco e se per
esempio gli è toccato in sorte il mare
dl il podestà dovrà elencare quali sono
le virtù del mare le ragioni della sua
bellezza la sua importanza per gli
uomini dovrà magari citare dei passaggi
storici biblici mitologici nei quali si
parla del mare cercando di dimostrare la
superiorità del proprio tema rispetto
agli altri e soprattutto la sua
superiorità e la sua abilità come poeta
improvvisatore vi mostro l'esempio del
poeta giuseppe porcu che improvvisa
un'ottava l'ottava è una delle forme di
poesia di improvvisazione utilizzate in
sardegna ed è una strofa composta da
otto versi endecasillabi quindi 8 versi
ognuno dei quali composti da 11 sillabe
e in questo caso le rime sono ab ab ab
cc si tratta di un'ottava di esordio
quindi che si trova all'inizio della
gara poetica che si è tenuta alcuni anni
fa a cagliari in onore del santo più
celebrato dell'isola che santifica
[Musica]
opporrà 2
fischio pro voto
[Risate]
un oro e due in fusto ed innocente ma la
samb santos uterino totò pregando scorsa
sarda gente e malamente orda sq losco no
tu o castello muta da deludente e lara
elkann tende in qeusta festa degna
saluto a tiglieto tasha giardini è per
darvi un'idea della varietà delle
tradizioni poi sempre visita in sardegna
vi mostro invece un estratto di una
repentina che è molto diversa dall
esempio che abbiamo visto prima e
diversa la lingua nella repentina si
improvvisa con il campidanese non come
con il logo do rese nell'esempio
precedente ed è diversa alla forma
metrica alla repentina e consiglio darà
un lungo flusso diversi che prevede
delle arretrò gas ovvero la ripetizione
di alcuni di questi versi però
modificando l'ordine interno delle
parole che compongono ognuno di questi
versi diverso e anche l'accompagnamento
nell'esempio precedente il poeta era
accompagnato da un coro composto da tre
voci gutturali in questo caso invece
sarà accompagnato da una fisarmonica
[Musica]
bene
non pretendo
sì
[Musica]
ma
segreti mai certi 8 posto una terra
[Musica]
apple
io crescevo una matta
il gol a denis savoca due cover assaggi
di sasha
h
ma nessun timore
[Musica]
no
sereni dari sonohra spider di stadi e tu
e scritto a me metto una con balli
[Musica]
ma sbaglia
a faccia su sky uno
[Musica]
io sì
non
un fatto
la poesia improvvisata non è un fenomeno
diffuso solo in sardegna in realtà la
troviamo diffusa in una grande
grandissima varietà di forme
praticamente in tutto il mondo in tutti
i continenti e ciò che mi interessa
evidenziare quale il fatto che a fronte
di una serie
potete immaginare importantissima di
differenze diverse sono le lingue le
forme metri che gli esiti musicali le
modalità con cui si conduce una gara
poetica la rilevanza sociale che nei
diversi paesi queste tradizioni hanno le
occasioni in cui vengono organizzate le
loro funzioni i loro significati
culturali
ecco a fronte di tutte queste differenze
in realtà tutte queste tradizioni del
mondo hanno alcuni tratti comuni per
esempio la dimensione contrastiva
competitiva agonistica i poeti devono
essere sempre almeno due sul palco
perché devono interagire tra loro non
fanno di monologhi o un altro aspetto
aspetto costante è la presenza della
musica
il fatto che i versi non vengono mai in
nessuna parte del mondo recitato
declamati sempre questi versi vengono
cantati e ancora il fatto che la poesia
dà vita a un evento performativo e in
molti casi come in sardegna rituale
complesso che prevede sempre il colpo il
coinvolgimento del pubblico della della
società del paese del gruppo sociale che
assiste alla gara ed è proprio la
presenza di questi tratti ricorrenti che
ci porta a pensare che la poesia
improvvisata sia una modalità espressiva
profondamente insita nella creatività
umana una forma di comunicazione
simbolica che gli uomini hanno elaborato
e raffinato nel corso dei secoli per
esprimere le proprie emozioni per
conservare la memoria collettiva per
intrattenere e informare il pubblico per
condividere il senso di comunità
attraverso la musica
i versi e il canto per non rimanere solo
in sardegna aprirci a un confronto
internazionale nel ringraziarvi per
l'attenzione vorrei salutarvi con un
ultimo esempio con un esempio di un
passatore ovvero un poeta improvvisatore
argentino che improvvisa su una forma
metrica molto bella molto
tant'e che si chiama decima composto
appunto da 10 versi accompagnandosi con
la chitarra che suona un ritmo di
milonga
[Musica]
[Applauso]
piegare mano
l'unico che sa chi lo sa
le cannet
[Musica]
e l'errore che poveri
questo è il modo con cui si improvvisa
nell'aria rioplatense tra argentina
uruguay come vedete un sistema molto
diverso da quello della sardegna ma
altrettanto affascinante le gare
poetiche come vi dicevo si tengono
soprattutto d'estate solo tra gli eventi
culturali di cui il virus ci ha privato
nel 2020 nell'estate del 2020 non si
sono tenute le gare poetiche in piazza i
poeti sono rimasti a casa hanno
continuato ad allenarsi e praticare la
poesia tra loro nella speranza che la
prossima estate potremo rivederci tutti
assieme sulle piazze ascoltare le loro
improvvisazioni
[Musica]